[Musique]
bonsoir tous nos petits amis oui nous
voici de retour est bien content de vous
retrouver ou n'est-ce pas nounours oui
oui oui bien sûr mais qu'est ce que tu
as tu semble inquiet oui je suis inquiet
patron vous n'avez peut-être pas
remarqué mais nous sommes suivis et
j'aimerais bien savoir partie par un
avion ou par un oiseau de nuit nous non
certainement pas je descends chez mes
amis mais je ne suis pas tranquille
ah ça non
je ne suis pas tranquille hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop
sinon ce
petit malheureux ne fait pas de bruit
je me le demande
quelqu'un suit notre nuage
[Musique]
tétouan il y a de quoi
dans le ciel ça m'étonnerait c'est de
l'attrapé mais je ne sais pas ce que
c'est ça brille us a disparu ça revient
un sens disparaît exactement
oui comme le furet
[Musique]
il connaît tout elle fera du poids mais
tant qu il court il court le furet le
ferais tu vois je lis il a passé par ici
il
a passé par ici il
court le furet laisserai qu'eva joly il
repassera par l'ordre la ferrari
[Musique]
n
a qu il court il court le furet les crs
du porge ali il a passé par ici il
a passé par ici il
court il court le furet qui fait
aujourd'hui il a passé par ici il
repassera
[Musique]
une housse ont-ils à présent
au
petit coquin vous vous moquez de moi
mais j'arrive très bien à savoir qui se
promène dans le ciel la nuit regarde
avec des jumelles avait des grosses
semaines exactement il me faudrait un
télescope
[Musique]
oui un
télescope
bonne nuit à deux bons amis à des lignes
le tipa brenets c'est quoi un télescope
c'est ca télescope va demander à papa
c'est ça demain matin nous lui
demanderons bonne nuit mon petit frère
aux nuits comme ça fait beau rêve
[Musique]
vous n'avez rien aperçu patron non non
non c'est bizarre mais j'en aurai le
korn est froid de nounours route en
route bonne nuit les enfants embrasser
bien fort vos parents n'oubliez pas de
faire votre toilette l'avez vous bien
les dents allez vite vous coucher et
effets de bord air
[Musique]